John Chrissy are you exhausted happy
birthday that's John Legend and Chrissy
Teigen on Sunday at the Critics Choice
Awards seemingly a bit snoozy after
going all out for John's 40th the night
before to get ready this was a huge
mistake
rewind to Saturday nights the couple
transformed their home into a can casino
for John's James Bond theme 40th
birthday bash
Chrissy looked stunning in gold while
their daughter Luna was too cute in a
sparkly ballerina dress so beautiful the
party was star-studded now the bond 40
birthday party for John Kim Kardashian
came with hubby Kanye West they hit the
elaborate photobooth with the birthday
boy so did Jesse Tyler Ferguson and hair
guru Jen Atkin Angela Bassett and
husband Courtney B Vance were also there
John took a moment to give a heartfelt
speech the best team Chrissy spoke to
her speech was well it was very Chrissy
I missed a lot in your 40 years
[Applause]
imagine I can imagine what we do in the
next 40 or you might die next year
[Music]